language is one of the most primary
facts of our existence it's something
that you say what is human
well many animals have methods of
communicating with one another but none
of them have our kind of extremely
elaborate grammar so it is a it's it's
it's right dead smack in the center of
what it is to be him and the ability to
tell a story there is another theory
that has it that the narrative art is an
evolved adaptation which we got in the
Pleistocene because those who had it had
a much greater edge they had a much
greater survival edge on those who did
not have it if I can tell you that right
over there in that River was where the
crocodile ate uncle George
you do not have to test that out in your
own life by going over there and getting
eaten by the crocodile and I can tell
you all sorts of other things that are
very useful to you for survival in your
world if I can tell you a story and we
know that people learn and assimilate
information much more through stories
than they do through charts and graphs
and statistics you might want to back up
those things with the math but what
really hits people is the story because
it's not an intellectual thing and it's
not just a scream it's not pure emotion
it's a melding of those two things which
is where we exist as human beings we're
not thought machines we're not screaming
machines we are thought feeling machines
if we're machines at all let's pretend
we're not we are thought feeling
entities in fact some people have done
Studies on it say that if you remove the
emotion from the person through some
accident they have a lot of trouble
making decisions because they try to
reason everything out and you actually
can't it's it's endless
a lot of people sing in the bathtub it
sounds really good
it's got acoustics in there but they're
not singers by that I don't mean that
they can't or don't sing I mean that
it's not their profession to sing people
do not pay them to stand on a stage and
make noises come out of their mouth so
it's it's partly and partly a difference
of job we love those moments and in
amateur in amateur night shows which
have now become so big like American
Idol and does Britain have talent etc we
just love that moment when the person
steps forward who has been a garage
mechanic or something and bursts into
prize-winning opera we just love it
Oh it sort of chokes you up because I
think it appeals to our humaneness it's
it's okay this is something we all might
possibly do even if we do have some
other job that we don't like very much
and people who say that ordinary people
aren't interested in the arts or just
dead wrong everybody kind of is and they
all do something in their life it's like
that even if it's woodworking in the
cellar or knitting their own special
knit patterns they're doing something
creative because we are very creative
species the difference between everybody
doing much no matter what their day job
may be and the people who are
professionals is that the people who are
professionals have somehow been able to
cross that threshold to the place where
they have an informed audience and where
they can scratch a living out of it in
some way so I think that's partly it and
in order to in order to do that you have
to be probably pretty dedicated that is
you have to put them the work in it you
have to put the practice in as I say to
people you can't just sit down at the
piano and be a concert pianist
that there's the part where you have to
practice and there's the drudgery
there's the work there's the hours I
think it's Malcolm Gladwell it has a
theory about how many hours you have to
put in to get really good at something
and that is why I will never ever be a
star ballet dancer however however much
I may like to leap about I am NOT that
person because I did not start when I
was 12 or whatever it was and put in the
practice